starting in 2003 American Chopper
dominated reality television for ten
years giving a look at the inside
workings of Orange County Choppers with
a mix of competition and drama that
provided a model for all reality shows
that have followed
unlike most so-called reality shows
though the fighting cursing crying
welding and painting on American Chopper
was real here's a look at the untold
truth of American Chopper drinking and
welding in his book the ride of a
lifetime
Paul Tuttle senior discusses his 15
years drug and alcohol addiction which
ended when he went to rehab on the
advice of his wife in 1985 he wrote
somehow she talked me into going into
rehab something I thought I'd never do
but I wanted to have one last good drunk
so the day before I was set to go into
rehab I got totally plastered I drank a
half gallon of wine a pint of brandy and
I took six valiance while Paul senior
was ultimately able to stop his drinking
his sons Mikey and Paul jr. both had
issues with drugs and alcohol with Paul
jr. going to rehab at age 16 father-son
Feud fights between the Paul's were a
regular occurrence on the show driving
much of the on-screen drama but the most
heated argument ever captured on camera
happened in 2009 when a chair throwing
Paul jr. was dressed down by his father
for sleeping on the job and showing up
late
it seems like the perfect reality TV
show plotline but this wasn't scripted
drama Paul senior actually fired his son
which opened a whole new can of worms
because the show's contract stipulated
that Paul jr. had to be involved the
network plc filed a notice of default
forcing Paul senior to bring Paul jr.
back as the contractors we could stay on
the show without technically working for
his dad but then things got even uglier
the new contract had a clause that
allowed Paul senior to buy out his son
steak in Orange County Choppers jr.
refused and dad sued him for a million
dollars Jr took into court and won
retaining his stake in the company but
the two eventually decided it would be
better for their relationship if they
just stopped working together entirely a
tragic accident in 2010 Paul jr.
branched out and opened his own custom
motorcycle shop
Paul jr. designs but the business began
under a dark cloud shortly after opening
a man contracted by the building's owner
to repair the roof fell and died in a
statement Paul jr. said quote this was a
tragic accident and although I've never
met this man my deepest condolences and
prayers go out to his family and friends
wedding snub in 2010 Paul jr. married
Rachel beyster a model he'd met on an
episode of American Chopper in advance
of their wedding the couple appeared on
TLC's show say yes to the dress and even
met with a chef from TLC's Cake Boss to
really hammer home the fact that TLC
pretty much owns these people one person
however did not attend Paul and Rachel's
wedding Paul senior who skipped the
event even though he was invited outch
case of stolen idea in 2014 a Florida
man named Chris to Vance's sued the two
Paul's and Orange County Choppers for
copyright infringement two Vance's who
suffered from polio and was wheelchair
bound until his death in February 2016
claim that he picked the idea of a
handicapped accessible three-wheeled
motorcycle two members of the shop at a
bike show in 2008 two Vance's contended
that this bike which the American
Chopper team built at the beginning of
2010 in conjunction with the Christopher
and Dana Reeve Foundation was a ripoff
of his original idea for which
manses held a patent honestly I honestly
from the bottom art that we were honored
to do this bike it's all about giving
back so we're doing this as of the
making of this video the case is still
making its way through the court system
sidekicks gone wild while his father and
brother were settling their differences
on screen and in court younger son Mikey
shifted his energy from Orange County
Choppers to other schemes in November
2010 he opened wolfgang gallery and art
gallery that showcase among other work
his own paintings a year after he opened
the gallery mikey launched the line of
gourmet pasta sauces under the company
name for new products which carried
flavors like port sonora g sausage
supreme one of the show's other lovable
sidekicks didn't have such a pleasant
end to its time with Orange County
Choppers chopped and Cody Connelly was a
regular in the show's early days and at
one point was given a chopper for all
his hard work which he helped design
however Cody later filed a lawsuit for
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in damages claiming that he never
received the chopper and that Orange
County Choppers continued to use his
likeness on promotional materials after
he'd left the company he eventually
settled out of court and returned to the
shelves but working for Paul jr. instead
rumors and lies in recent years Orange
County Choppers has been dogged by
persistent rumors that the company is in
dire financial straits and headed for
foreclosure when word got out that their
headquarters was being sold Paul senior
had to go on the radio to assure fans
that they were doing fine around the
same time as the foreclosure rumors
started swirling strange reports
surfaced that Justin's all senior had
died in a motorcycle accident
according to snopes.com on April 18 2016
the website iron demon doctored a real
article about another man's death in a
motorcycle crash in Louisiana to make it
look like it was Paul seniors death the
rumors went viral
prompting Orange County Choppers to post
a rebuttal on Facebook the show may be
dead for now but it stars at least are
still alive and kicking thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love sue
[Music]